[Music]
welcome to the special edition of
Hannity the fake news epidemic and
tonight for the hour we're going to show
you the worst of the worst examples from
the mainstream media and their
unprecedented assault against President
Trump now this includes the top fake
news anchors reporters the biggest anti
Trump print media outlets and the most
inexcusable example of the media
spreading fake news to you the American
people will also show you president
Trump's most epic takedowns of the
liberal mainstream media after
announcing his campaign the president
had faced an onslaught of historically
negative media coverage and on Monday
the president will continue to fight
back against these attacks by unveiling
what he's calling the most dishonest and
corrupt media awards of the year now
before we get to all of that as
important to show you just how abusively
biased the anti-trump media really is
and it starts with the media saying
Donald Trump would never win would never
become the president take a look Donald
Trump has been saying that he will run
for president as a Republican which is
surprising since I just assumed he was
running as a joke do it now on behalf of
this country which does not want you to
be President but which Bradley wants you
to run this man has got some momentum
and we better be ready for the fact that
he may be leading the Republican ticket
which Republican candidate has the best
chance of winning the general election
of the declared ones right now Donald
Trump
[Applause]
mr. Trump to answer your call for
political honesty I just want to say
you're not going to be President all
right it's been fun President Obama will
go down as perhaps the worst president
in the history of the United States
exclamation point at real Donald Trump
at real Donald Trump at least I will go
down as a president and then on election
night after Trump study victory it was
like a funeral for the mainstream media
you may remember some of this America is
crying tonight I'm not sure how much of
America but a very very significant
portion and I mean literally crying this
is a sadness it is a a mourning moment
for those people and it is a it is a
moment filled with fear filled with fear
our country is about to face some
serious crises and so your country needs
you it's a pretty extraordinary thing to
say if you have a son in the marine
corps and that you don't trust the
commander in chief the people in the
military defend the Constitution this
was a white lash this was a white lash
against a changing country
it was a white lash against a black
president in part and since the election
the media has done everything possible
to try and damage President Trump by
pushing of course the Trump Russia
Russia Russia collusion narrative
despite no evidence so whatsoever at
this point look at this non-stop
shameful coverage I think this is a
potentially more dangerous situation
than Watergate and we're at a very
dangerous moment and that's because we
are looking at the possibility that the
President of the United States and those
around him during an election campaign
colluded with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane vladimer if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion
there's outright treason I mean there is
no question
that what he is doing is giving aid and
comfort to the enemy
specifically Willie I think what it
means is that a federal judge found that
people in Trump's organization were
colluding with the Russians but first we
want to start with this week in Russia
gate it is as if there are no shoes on
the Trump Human Centipede that are not
about Russia Russia Russia Russia this
cloud about collusion with Russia will
hang over him no matter where he stand
it certainly feels like we're in the
opening stages of a devastating
political chapter in American history
evidence is mounting for the president's
meddling in the Russia probe Tom
Friedman said the election hacking is at
the caliber of a Pearl Harbor or a 9/11
to agree with that I completely agree
with that Donald Trump now sits at the
threshold of impeachment I personally
think it's over I don't think there's
anything that can be done that can stop
this at this point cacophony this
gushing of lies problems questions chaos
that will stop this presidency in its
tracks you told The Washington Post last
week that quote there's a smell of
treason in the air when it comes to this
investigation a lot of people are afraid
to use the T word treason but in the end
that's what people are investigating it
does look like collusion it does look
like he's listening to Putin more than
he is American intelligence and frankly
I've never seen that before
pretty unbelievable joining us now with
reaction former deputy assistant to the
president Fox News contributor Sebastian
Gorka and Fox News contributor Herman
Cain you know dr. korkor they never
expected this they they they couldn't
they were shocked by it all it was a
funeral on November 8th 2016 but the
worst part is ever since there's been an
effort to undo or to D legitimize this
president and get him out of office any
by any means necessary so it gets really
serious yeah I mean not only did they
not expect it remember the New York
Times in The Huffington Post said on the
night of the election Hillary has more
than a 95 percent chance of winning
winning not only not only do they not
expect it they still can't believe
for all the talk in this awful new book
and across the media about mental
competence in the White House do you
know who needs mental help Sean all the
people you just showed in your montage I
mean they dream
they need men mental health
professionals to help them I just had a
journalist asked me today
based upon them the Michael Wolfe book
is it true that the president doesn't
like anyone touching his toothbrush Sean
journalism journalism North Korea has
nuclear missiles the president's
defeated Isis China's on the March I
mean and they want to talk about the
president's toothbrush this is a bad
skit it's insanity it is a form of
insanity I'm not disagreeing with you
Herman Cain you experienced all this
firsthand
you can speak from your experience how
bad this is but it's still a lot worse
for president Trump it is and that
opening montage was fantastic it shows
that the jokes on the jokesters and the
lies on the liberals and it also
indicates as mr. Gorka alluded to that
TDS Trump derangement syndrome is an
addiction because the results don't
matter they don't care about the results
of 2017 it's all about Trump derangement
syndrome and if I can borrow a metaphor
from Mike Huckabee
addicts that are drug addicts
some of them recover but the media TDS
addicts they show no signs of recovery
they are in a hole and they keep digging
and they can't get out that's what this
illustrates and is sad for the country
because we have dependence so long on
the media to give us the truth and now
we know that they cannot they are
incapable of being able to do that
you know dr. Cortes you look at you know
then the year of really trying to get
them out of office that's what their
goal is pet but if at a lower level is
to do
legitimise and the words the adjectives
that are used on an hourly basis on
cable TV and in supposedly you know hard
news journalistic centers ABC CBS NBC is
the worst and you know Washington Post
New York Times that they use to describe
the president are they hurt in the
office they're hurting the whole country
Sean this is the duly elected president
of the most powerful nation in the world
and they don't recognize that he is the
president they use the kinds of language
we've never ever seen before
not with Nixon not with Reagan they are
doing things that are utterly outrageous
for a blogger to do on mainstream cable
television but Sean can I tell you the
good news the good news is very simple
Fox you your colleagues are crushing it
with viewers like three four million
people a night Anderson Cooper cracks
open a bottle of champagne if 600,000
people watch him they are becoming
irrelevant I'm an American citizen now
and I'm proud to be and you know what
defines us common sense when you get out
of the bubble they couldn't care less
about Michael Wolff they couldn't care
less about Don Lemon they want to see
their paycheck in February be bigger
than it was in January they want to see
Isis crushed so the American people see
through through the lies and they tune
in to your show and that's great news
what do you make Herman of the what I
call the this is the year of the
boomerang in other words now we know
that the Clinton Foundation is and has
been for months investigated which it
should be now we know they've reopened
an investigation into the email server
scandal then we know that Comey and
Peter struck literally rigged that
investigation months before writing an
exoneration letter before an
investigation all of these things now
and and Trump Russia collusion dying out
it seems that there's been a dramatic
turn of events that the media never
expected
did they ever admit at some point they
were wrong about Trump and Russia do
they look at Hillary Clinton funding a
dossier full of lies Russian propaganda
law
and salacious material and say that
could be collusion was it used for a
FISA warrant I mean to me these this is
all flipped on them
they will never admit it now remember
the case on Hillary Clinton was closed
during the Obama administration it has
now been reopened under the Trump
administration and even though Jeff
Sessions gets a lot of criticism I
happen to believe based upon all the
reports and the information we know and
based upon the outrage of Congress I
happen to believe based upon that alone
Hillary is going down secondly it is
clear that the Liberals and the
Democrats have only one strategy and it
was used decades ago if you keep telling
a lie often enough over and over and
over sooner or later some people are
going to believe it
the thing is most of the people that are
already believed in a lie are already
believing a lie
they aren't going to convert new people
who are conservative voices out there
even though we are outnumbered Sean I
truly believe we are saving some of
disabled all right thank you both for
being with us we really appreciate it